I wouldn't say it's a bike or lazy
people which a lot of people think when
they think electric cyclist so it's more
like an action by
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
something between a motorcycle and
normal cycle you can control the
electric power so you you choose how
much you wanna use it but the actual
trial is really really tiring it gives
you a good workout it's just a hobby
really at the time it was an idea
concept you know let me build my own
bike and I think was about three months
later I did have my own bike it was on
my own mountain bike yeah this
definitely looked like a Frankenstein
bike in your batteries everywhere wires
everywhere it was faster but it was just
too scary to ride because it's just too
light is that okay well at least the
concept was there and then we're like
this could be a viable business and you
know electric bike was something that
was going in around the world you have
to design a bike which is more for the
uiu market you know which is something
you can take out and actually use on the
dunes so look is a local dog breed which
is very skinny it's very fast and it's
quite it's a desert dog so it really
fits within our brand that's why we
picked it
but the fat bikes are made for the
desert mainly and and they can go up to
45 km/h and the desert quietly without
disturbing any you know wildlife without
creating any issues in the desert and
it's a really seamless Drive I mean
there was one of the amazing things when
riding on the bike the first time you
know desert foxes I saw desert rabbits I
saw website show lizards things I never
saw riding my quadrant in the back of
the desert before and it's just in
silence see just it's you in the wind it
was phenomenal
just riding on the ridges of the sand
dunes Sun Goes Down it's just amazing
we've got to try it I mean one thing
that we've noticed anyone that gets on
these bikes they come back with a big
swamp
you
[Music]